it's a truth universally acknowledged
that with great power
comes great responsibility taking into
account both the comics and the tv
series here are some of the worst things
the umbrella academy has ever done
whether you're talking about the comics
or the tv series there's no denying
reginald hargreaves is the worst
after all he probably caused all those
spontaneous
non-consensual pregnancies through his
magic alien sparkles resulting in the
births of the hargreaves children
and then he raised the seven kids he was
able to purchase
in a sterile unloving environment where
his only focus was on the children's
special abilities and not their
emotional needs yet while hargreaves
mistreated all of his adopted children
to varying degrees
it's no contest when it comes to which
one of the hargreaves siblings drew the
shortest straw
poor vanya hargreaves was raised to
believe she had no powers at all and was
therefore
unworthy in every sense of the word it's
only once she becomes
an adult that she learns she's actually
the most powerful of the seven
and that her father had been suppressing
her abilities with medication her whole
life
claiming she needed it to regulate her
mental health
not only did he lie to vanya for decades
but he excluded her from the umbrella
academy's missions
causing her to feel distanced from her
family and doubt her own self-worth
i'm afraid there's just nothing special
about you reginald hargreaves was a
horrible father no matter how you slice
it but his treatment of vania took the
cake
as a child alison hargreaves received
her superhero moniker the rumor thanks
to her ability to use her voice to
convince
anyone to do anything she wanted with a
gift like that
the world is truly alison's oyster and
once she leaves home as a teenager she
uses it to her
full advantage alison rumors herself
into fame
and fortune which while definitely not
the most forthright way to engage with
the world
at least doesn't seem to be hurting
anyone however she crosses a line
in both the comics and the series when
it's implied that she rumors a man
named patrick into falling in love with
her and subsequently marrying her
while we never get a detailed look at
alison and patrick's relationship it
seems that at some point
alison told patrick about her powers and
agreed to stop using them
however their marriage fell apart when
he caught her using her powers on their
daughter
claire good luck on your next film i
hope it turns out better than your
marriage
dysfunctional is honestly a pretty tame
way of describing the dynamic among the
hargreaves siblings
but at least the netflix characters make
slightly more of an effort to establish
meaningful relationships with one
another than the siblings in the comics
do
however one place in which the tv heroes
really drop the ball is toward the end
of the first season of the umbrella
academy
when the men of the hargreaves family
utterly disregard the opinions and
suggestions of their sisters
after luther realizes how powerful vanya
is he betrays her trust when she returns
home to ask for help
choking her unconscious and locking her
in a soundproof bunker underneath the
mansion
vanya pleads with him to let her out but
he refuses to listen to her
alison whose throat vania slit in a fit
of rage also demands that luther release
vanya but
he won't listen to her either later
after vanya escapes and destroys the
academy alison beseeches her brothers to
try to talk to vanya but this time all
of them ignore her and attempt to attack
vanya instead which does not go well
not only does this strip both vanya and
alison of their agency
but with the men calling all the shots
the women are literally robbed of their
voices
in both the comics and the tv show klaus
also known as the seance and number 4
winds up time traveling back to the 60s
where he enlists in the army and fights
in the vietnam war
however the details of klaus's time in
the 60s are very different and while the
tv series sees him
falling in love with and then witnessing
the death of a young soldier named dave
the comics don't give him a tragic love
story instead they give him a job
running a nightclub and creating a
televator
a sort of tardis-like transport
originally invented by reginald
hargreaves that allows occupants to
travel through space-time and other
dimensions
when it's finally time for klaus diego
and luther to head back to their time in
the televator klaus hands an
unexplained baby he'd been carrying
around off to a local vietnamese woman
it turns out that much to everyone's
surprise the baby belongs to klaus
although we never learn anything about
the mother or even the baby's name
truthfully it's probably good that klaus
realized he had no business raising a
baby
on the other hand especially given his
own upbringing it seems rather callous
that he just casually hands off his own
child
without much of a thought before
departing forever and he never mentions
his offspring ever again
both the second season of netflix is the
umbrella academy
and the second volume of the comics
center around the assassination of john
f kennedy but
the way it plays out in each is very
different
in both the tv series and the comics
number five winds up
duking it out with his older self after
he's tasked with killing the president
but in the tv show it's actually the
sinister majestic 12 organization that
carries out the assassination plot
absolving the umbrella academy of any
role in the death
however in the comics things play out
very differently after witnessing a
cataclysmic future in which kennedy
survives
setting off a chain of events leading to
the end of the world five travels to the
past intent on making sure the
assassination is carried out
like in the show his brothers are
determined to stop the assassination
but five has accounted for this just
when his siblings think they've stopped
the assassination
we see that alison has taken jackie
kennedy's place in kennedy's car and she
rumors kennedy's head to explode
in season two of the netflix series
after the entire hargreaves clan
accidentally travels through time back
to the 60s klaus drops into the year
1960 alongside the ghost of his dead
brother
ben also known as the horror and number
six
ben died when they were all teenagers
but thanks to klaus's ability to
communicate with the dead
klaus has remained in constant
communication with him in the years
since
after becoming irritated with ben
however klaus lies to their siblings
after they've reunited telling them that
ghosts can't time travel when they ask
about ben
you need serious help it's played for
laughs in the show but if you think
about it this is a particularly cruel
thing for klaus to do to ben
numerous times ben voices how much he
misses his siblings and wishes to be
with them again
even though the rest of their siblings
express a desire to speak to ben and
klaus knows
he's ben's only connection to the rest
of the world he still refuses to
acknowledge ben's presence
klaus is likely motivated much more by
pettiness than any sort of real
maliciousness but even so
punishing your dead brother by refusing
to let him communicate with his loved
ones just because you're annoyed
is a pretty jerky thing to do in the
umbrella academy comics klaus is more of
a sad character than a comedic one but
in the tv series he largely serves to
provide some laughs
this is how it's framed when it's
revealed at the beginning of season 2
that klaus started a cult in the 1960s
while klaus didn't set out to start a
cult he quickly realized he could get
special treatment if he used his
knowledge of the future
and his powers to convince people that
he was some sort of oracle
klaus's cult which he dubs destiny's
children is
played almost entirely for laughs until
he eventually abandons them to return to
the future with his siblings
however in the real world cults are
deeply problematic organizations that
thrive on brainwashing manipulation
and abuse viewers know klaus isn't a
predatory person but he still wound up
brainwashing his followers through lies
and manipulation
after adopting his seven super-powered
children as babies
reginald hargreaves molds them into a
crime-fighting super team
but of course defeated super villains
have to go somewhere and in the comics
it's revealed that after being subdued
by the umbrella academy
reginald hargreaves ships off the cowed
baddies to the hotel oblivion
the hotel oblivion isn't really a hotel
at all but instead it's a prison located
in a hellish alternate dimension where
bad guys are locked inside
indefinitely a glimpse inside one
inmate's hotel oblivion experience
shows that residents gradually go mad
from isolation that the tvs play really
weird cartoons
and that the rooms are stocked with
hargreaves authored self-help literature
in the first season of the netflix show
vanya spends much of the season vying
for the competitive first chair violin
position in her local orchestra
at the end of the season she unleashes
her newly discovered powers and winds up
accidentally blowing a chunk off the
moon
triggering an apocalyptic event however
in the comics
the orchestra vanya joins isn't just a
regular musical group
instead it's an ensemble made up of
quote mad men
and murderesses intent on bringing about
the end of the world
and they call themselves the orchestra
for damton which translates to orchestra
of the damned
the conductor of the orchestra tries to
recruit vanya early on in order to help
them bring about their goal
but she refuses however once vanya
learns the truth of her powers and her
father's deception she returns to the
orchestra for dampton and voluntarily
joins their ranks
while it's understandable that vanya
would be deeply hurt after learning that
she's been lied to and manipulated her
entire life
joining a group bent on destroying the
world seems like overkill
this is one area where the netflix show
makes vanya much more sympathetic
banya's tour of destruction once she
realizes the extent of her family's
betrayal doesn't stop at her joining a
villainous orchestra
before she heads off to her fateful
performance she also unleashes her
powers on her family mansion
and in the process she kills the
family's primate caretaker pogo
throughout the lives of the hargreaves
siblings pogo has served as both a
mentor and a surrogate father figure
vanya feels understandably betrayed when
she learns that pogo was
in on reginald's secret but it still
seems like a bridge
too far when she kills him in cold blood
in the comics she uses her powers to
make his head explode while in the
netflix series she impales him on a pair
of antlers mounted above their fireplace
one of a handful of important characters
created just for the netflix series is
the cunning handler who works for the
temps commission and serves as both a
frequent ally and nemesis of number five
while the temps commission exists to
maintain and protect the timeline the
handler's role has always felt a little
more ambiguous and she always seems to
have a hidden agenda that serves only
herself
so it's worrisome when as a trade-off
for giving five a means to return
himself
and his siblings to their proper time
after getting stuck in the 60s she
requests that he assassinate the entire
board of directors of the commission
putting her in charge
granted 5 is rather desperate at the
time but that doesn't change the fact
that he's willing to hand over
control of time itself to someone
entirely untrustworthy and self-serving
all in the name of getting himself and
his siblings back home
no list of terrible actions committed at
the hands of the hargreaves family would
be complete
without mentioning the not one but two
apocalypses the siblings have managed to
cause
the first one occurs when vanya embraces
her powers as the white violin
and blows a chunk off the moon that then
comes hurtling toward earth
that apocalypse is thwarted in the
comics by seance and circumvented in the
show by five transporting all of his
siblings back in time
but even so there's no denying that the
actions of the umbrella academy caused
it in the first place
did that say anything about the
apocalypse when you spoke to him
the second takes place in the 60s after
the academy successfully prevents the
assassination of jfk which winds up
ultimately triggering a nuclear war with
the ussr
once again it's the hargreaves siblings
interfering in the timeline
that triggers the eventual apocalypse
proving that in the world of the
umbrella academy
it's true that no good deed goes
unpunished check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite comics and shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one